you know i never wanted this channel to
be about celebrities or public figures
but uh
over the last few years it's something i
found myself touching on more and more
be it as side notes and talking about
certain works that i already want to
talk about or
full videos talking about what the heck
happened and what i felt about it
and i've done it enough seen enough
content on similar topics
that i find myself thinking about the
patterns
and how these things go down because
there are really only so many paths
available
to public figures when controversy
strikes and which path they take
is going to have a significant impact on
whether or not they are deemed deserving
of a second chance
[Music]
the idea of second chances is something
i see brought up frequently
at least in comment responses whenever i
do videos on controversies around
individuals with plenty of commenters
saying why some given individual does or
doesn't
deserve a second chance those arguing
against are usually coming from a
position of what they did was so bad
there should be nothing else this is the
end of the road which is largely a call
based on personal values and therefore
one that i don't have any business
arguing with in the broad strokes
whether the fact that rob lowe had sex
with a 16 year old in 1988
means you don't feel comfortable
watching the west wing or not
that's a call that only you can make
however
on the flip side of the second chances
debate i do often
see things which amount to well if
person x was given a second chance then
person y
should get one too basically arguing a
position that
all these occurrences should be handled
the same way
and um if you've been around my channel
even for a little bit
you already know my answer to this
nothing
is ever always i even got a shirt with
that on it merch link in the description
situations can be similar for
numerous reasons but that doesn't make
them equivocal
the differences between each instance
matters but it helps to have
an approach to try and parse those
differences so here are the questions
that
i ask myself when these things come up
what is the nature and the credibility
of the accusations against the public
figure
is it in line or in contradiction with
that person's current public image
has the public figure responded if so
has the public figure expressed remorse
and how sincere is it
has the public figure expressed
intention to change how strong is the
evidence that such change is occurring
or at least being attempted
now let me be clear this isn't a
checklist this isn't something where i
expect
public figures to answer every question
in a specific way that suits me
personally
these are just the things that i'm going
to be looking for
when assessing my own ability to give
this person or that person
a second chance don't worry i'm going to
be going through these
and there will be examples mostly from
people i've already done videos on
conveniently enough i'd also like to
note that this same list of questions
can easily
be applied to a corporate entity facing
controversy for things like
discriminatory hiring or toxic work
environments
activision though for the sake of
simplicity i intend to limit most of my
examples to
individuals additionally i'm going to
try to be as
fair as possible in the examples i cite
but
just realize i'm not here to litigate
anybody's actions
i'm here to talk about the cycle of
controversy
responses to it and how that plays out
i may need two side examples but it's
not really what we're here to talk about
and pick apart cool
cool the nature and credibility of the
accusation
this first one is pretty straightforward
on paper
but it can get very messy very quickly
in practice
basically we're asking what is the
person accused of and how credible is
the accuser or
group of accusers now that second part
already adds complications
because in a one-on-one disagreement
battle lines are going to get drawn very
quickly because
until things get further along it's
largely going to be one person's word
against another
now if instead of a single accuser there
is a group of people behind the
accusation
either issuing similar allegations or
issuing statements of support
for the initial allegation it's
immediately going to lend more
credibility
we kind of saw this happen in real time
with the accusations against joss whedon
and his onset attitude during the
shooting of justice league
initially the accusations were pretty
much only coming from ray fisher
so for a while it was basically one
person's word against another
but as time went on fisher's co-stars
began to express their support
for him and then when people who worked
under whedon
on other projects began to come forward
with their own stories that lined up
with what fisher was saying
it was no longer a simple your word
against mine situation
it's also interesting to look at the
issue of credibility in relation to
whedon
because oftentimes fans are going to
rally around the accused person at least
initially since they want to believe the
best of the person who makes the thing
that they like
in the case of whedon the fans of dc
films
already didn't like him because many of
them held him at least
partially responsible for how far away
the theatrical release of justice league
was from what original director zack
snyder had hoped to make
so many actually jumped on the ray
fisher camp
much more rapidly than usually happens
in such situations now that sort of
related question i asked about whether
or not the accusations are in line with
the public figure's image
it doesn't apply in every case but i'll
give you two quick examples where it
does apply
one were things lined up and one where
they didn't in 2016
when audio leaked of then presidential
candidate donald j
trump bragging about sexually assaulting
women the traditional view of politics
was that this was the end
of his campaign but that didn't happen
and i'd argue that part of the reason
that this and many other similar
scandals never put a dent in trump's
political aspirations
was because all these things were
absolutely in line with the kind of
person trump actually purported to be
accusing someone like trump of being a
bully or objectifying women
doesn't carry much weight when nothing
about his public persona contradicts
those ideas
he was already famous for doing both of
those things to varying degrees
some of the things he was best known for
were firing people on television and
running a beauty pageant
the people who liked him already decided
they were okay
with some degree of this behavior so
just upping the degree of it didn't do
much to hurt him
on the other hand ellen degeneres saw
her entire brand image
nose dive when reports began to leak
about a toxic work environment on her
popular daytime show
including accusations of cruel and
bullying behavior from her
personally the reason these accusations
were so damaging
had less to do with the severity of the
specific instances and a whole lot more
to do with the fact that they
flew in the face of the be kind to each
other mentality
that ellen had built her entire brand on
the issue was less that ellen was mean
to people sometimes
than it was that her fans felt lied to
and deceived about who she even was by
these revelations
now so far i've been talking about
accusations relating to
behavior things get a lot messier when
controversy instead surrounds a public
figure's beliefs but stick a
pin in that we're gonna have to circle
back around to it
the response
next up how did the public figure
respond to
the controversy this one can honestly be
what makes or breaks the entire
situation i've noted before
that how one responds to accusations has
the power to
mitigate damage but it also can make
things much
much worse funnily enough this is
actually a bigger issue now than it used
to be
back in my day oh god i
actually said that all right i'm i'm
owning it now
back in my day before your fancy
twisters and your youtubes and your tiki
talks
i can't keep doing that voice uh but
back then the standard progress of a
scandal or controversy
was for the public figure to issue a
fairly middle-of-the-road statement and
then just
disappear from the public eye for a bit
often under the guise of some sort of
rehab or general self-improvement
this rarely does the trick anymore
and that's because of the joys of social
media back in the day
when a manager or a pr person all they
had to do when they had a client in
trouble
is get that public figure away from
where the cameras would be
and wait for the thing to blow over it
didn't always work but it was a proven
first step
at least if the public figure couldn't
say these things to journalists or on
camera
then they couldn't make it any worse but
now
unless a manager is able to take away
their client's phone completely
the public figure still has access to
twitter instagram
youtube and a ton of other platforms
where they are free to speak
without a filter which isn't to say that
there aren't still some who
know how to stop talking just that it
seems to be a
vanishing skill a solid example of
someone who pulled that
old school approach off quite well in
relatively recent memory
was rosario dawson in late 2019 dawson
and several members of her family
were accused of verbally emotionally and
even physically
harassing and assaulting a transgender
man who worked for them
that man went on to file a lawsuit over
the whole issue
dawson threw a statement by her attorney
denied the accusations but otherwise
said
nothing she didn't talk about the case
she didn't talk about the man who
accused her
she just did not talk about it and then
when she was dropped from the lawsuit
nearly a full year later in august of
2020 the general reaction seemed to
amount to
oh that that was still going on dawson
seemed to understand
that any statement made was going to be
heavily scrutinized so it was best to
simply say
nothing at all that said she had the
slight advantage
of this actually playing out in court so
any statements she did feel the need to
make
could be confined to the court
proceedings
instead of having to be aired publicly
or feeling like they had to be aired
publicly
when accusations exist primarily or
exclusively in the public arena
then that's usually the only place that
you can answer them
it's also worth acknowledging that it's
going to be easier for someone like
rosario dawson to basically go
silent because of the nature of her
celebrity
as an actress fans are used to engaging
with her work anywhere from a few times
a year to once every couple of years
because there's down time between her
projects
but for any public figure whose image is
heavily dependent on social media
it's gonna be much harder and possibly
more detrimental to just go
silent so this applies to youtubers tic
talkers instagram influencers
or even authors actors or video game
developers if
they have a high degree of fan
engagement through online platforms
if a person's fame and notoriety is even
partly due to their
online presence as opposed to their
actual works
then disengaging from online presence
carries a much more
substantial risk but if your fans are
used to having access to you
and you're not talking about what the
scandal is it looks bad
flip side is if you keep responding to
the controversy
that means you're keeping it in the
public eye and are risking saying
something that will make it worse
but then if you simply unplug you've
basically completely cut off your entire
platform which may begin hemorrhaging
engagement or relevance in the absence
of new content
this is why i have alerts on my phone to
remind me to tweet something other than
hey i've got a new video up at least
once a day
because if i don't it might as well be a
faceless corporate account and i ain't
that big yet
to be able to be a faceless corporation
maybe one day is that the dream
god i hope not now this whole thing is
probably why online based celebrities
like logan paul jeffree star shane
dawson pewdiepie and others
can't seem to stay out of trouble simply
stepping out of the limelight really
isn't an option for them their entire
celebrity and brand
is online and even if they try and
disengage
those online spaces are going to keep
talking about them
was there an apology we've gone on a
while and that's just on the topic about
statements being issued at
all so let's talk about how these
controversies get addressed when
statements are
made so there's a couple of options that
these people have first there's the flat
denial simply saying none of this is
true
which makes the strongest statement but
is also a bit of a gamble
and it can backfire because if a public
figure
unambiguously denies an accusation
and later there turns out to be solid
credible backing behind it then the
public figure gets to add
liar onto their list of accusations
and this can happen even if only part of
the accusation is found to be true
that's the risk of a hard-line denial it
leaves you no
wiggle room if it turns out later that
at least some bits of this
were true i think that's why you usually
only see
hard-line denials when it comes to the
most egregious of accusations usually
sexual or violent in nature because at
that point the accusation is
so bad that admitting fault to even part
of it it simply might not be an option
from a pr
perspective again unless you're somebody
like
trump who already has nasty behavior as
part of his established
image where you get some more wiggle
room
next there's what i consider to be sort
of the industry standard
the non-apology this is where a
statement is made in the style of an
apology without actually taking
ownership
of the action or admitting to any fault
they tend to contain
phrases like i'm sorry if anyone was
offended or i'm sorry people
felt that way which contains the words
i'm sorry and
acknowledges people's feelings but does
not admit to any fault
to the original actions there's also i'm
sorry that my loved ones have to hear
this or i'm sorry that i've disappointed
my fans which
again is kind of an apology but
conveniently it's not an apology that
engages with the actual people
who say they've been wronged now these
honestly
really never help because they're so
ubiquitous
that the problem with them is they're
just easily called out
but they still get deployed because
sometimes it's the best option under the
circumstances
of course if the public figure is flatly
denying accusations then
they're not going to apologize at all
because it reads as an admission of
guilt
now if fault is admitted to
then the question becomes are they
admitting to this
because there's too much evidence anime
a culpa is kind of their only option
or are they admitting to this because
they genuinely recognize that they've
done
something wrong for the former option
let's look at someone like
perez hilton hilton made his name as
something of a professional
troll making fun of celebrities in petty
and hurtful ways
even outing some celebrities as gay who
hadn't come out
publicly yet something he's still
never explicitly apologized for in 2010
perez teamed with the it gets better
project
on anti-bullying work and put out a
video pledging to do better and to no
longer harass celebrities as he had
previously now
there wasn't really specific allegations
against him in the news at the time
but the evidence of his bullying
behavior was all over the internet it
was quite literally his
brand but the tide was turning against
the way he'd been
operating so he opted to pivot and given
that he's done some messed up
stuff since then specifically relating
to lady gaga and ariana grande it really
does appear more like he just thought it
was the best move for his career
and less like he had much sincere regret
on the flip side there's the relatively
recent allegations against
warren ellis ellis is a writer best
known for his comic book works
such as trans metropolitan and red along
with being the writer for the netflix
series adaptation of castlevania
in june of 2020 ellis was faced with
allegations from multiple women of
various kinds of manipulation
gaslighting coercion and emotional abuse
ellis's response only denied any intent
to harm but he didn't refute the
accounts of these women
and was pretty forthcoming about his own
culpability he stated that he'd failed
to understand the power dynamic at play
in his encounters with women
and had not recognized how the balance
was automatically in his favor
due to his standing in the industries
that he worked in
if sincere the response paints a picture
of a man who
is being made to recognize the reasons
why behavior he thought
wasn't a problem actually was at no
point did he accuse anyone of lying or
trying to ruin him he immediately
stepped away from all his projects even
going so far as to ask
dc comics to not use a story he'd
already written and submitted
to them for an upcoming anthology i
believe it was batman
and he's kept quiet since then
ostensibly working on self-improvement
through therapy now whether this is a
case of sincere regret
or someone simply having a better
understanding of the current landscape
and going farther than usual to take
ownership
as part of a calculated move to mitigate
the damage
is frankly impossible to say at this
point but
so far at least ellis has yet to do
anything that has brought doubt onto his
statements
unlike the somewhat similar situation
with comedian louis c.k
who's replied to accusations of
self-exposure came
at things from a similar position and
amounted to i didn't recognize that my
position of power meant people
might say something was okay when it
actually absolutely was not
now ck has stepped back into the
limelight since then and some
feel a bit too quickly since he began
appearing
on comedy stages less than a year after
the major accusations against him
and getting back into that arena that
quickly can't help but make some
question
how sincere his apology was having said
that no actual new allegations have
occurred so far as i can find
so how about we shift into
desire to change so we've started
talking about this with some of the
examples already given
but if there is an admission of guilt
somewhere then the question is whether
or not the public figure expressed any
desire to change their behavior
now this isn't going to be the case on
most of the more severe
accusations of misconduct but for
something that could be painted as
either a one-off incident
or a pattern of behavior that's now
regretted
then there is the possibility of doing
better in the future it's actually
pretty rare
for public figures to evoke the it was a
mistake i only made one time
argument and for pretty good reason in
an age when so much is recorded and it's
all searchable on the internet public
figures have learned
the hard way that if they claim
something only happened once
but that's not actually true then it's
virtually a guarantee that the internet
will dig up the other times that it
happened my own favorite example of this
is somebody who
actually wasn't really a well-known
public figure outside
of his particular niche corner of the
internet but it's such a perfect example
and furthermore
hilarious i'm going to use it anyway
philip
musen was an internet video game critic
who
in 2018 was accused of plagiarizing his
review
of the game dead cells from a channel
called boomstick gaming
the similarities between his video and
boomstick gaming's original were
undeniable and ign which was employing
museum at the time
promptly fired him and placed all the
work he'd done for them under review to
ensure that nothing else looked to be
plagiarized
musin didn't deny the similarities to
boomstick gaming's video
i mean he really couldn't everybody
could see them but he tried to claim it
was unintentional
and he then did the single stupidest
thing he could have possibly done
in his response to all this while
calling out the site kotaku which was
running its own investigation at the
time
he said and i quote you can keep looking
kotaku
and please let me know if you find
anything
he dared not only his colleagues in the
industry but the internet at large to
find more instances of him plagiarizing
work
and guess what happened next
mountains of evidence from years worth
of work was
unearthed and brought to light stuff
that probably wouldn't even have been
found by kotaku if he hadn't
goaded everybody so yeah this kind of
thing is why you don't see
it only happened that one time used very
much
as a defense anymore however something
similar to
it only happened one time still does get
some use
and that's well things went too far now
this is the path taken by people like
logan paul and pewdiepie whenever they
get into trouble and need to admit to
fault
in both cases what they got into trouble
for uploading a video of the body of a
man who committed suicide
and paying people to make him a video of
them holding an anti-semitic sign
respectively
aren't a million miles away from their
normal output
paul was well known for his vlogs
depicting the things he did or saw on
pewdiepie had a long history of
quote-unquote
edgy jokes so neither could really
disown the behavior that led up to these
incidents without completely changing
their entire image and approach to
content
which is part of why neither apology was
taken as very sincere because
there was no recognition of how their
behavior
up to the point of going quote unquote
too far
had led them to that point only the
acknowledgement that they crossed of
line
of course both have had further
controversy since then but
i'm not going down that particular
rabbit hole thank you very much
evidence of change so that leaves people
who make sincere pledges to change which
is a really hard thing to sell because
it requires that they actually
do change and more importantly prove
that they plan to keep to those changes
even as time passes and the passage of
time is a
big factor here but it's also possibly
one of the reasons that mitigating
damage is so difficult because most
public figures
want to be granted their second chance
right away if only in the interest of
preserving their careers
but for many of their fans or former
fans what's needed more than anything
is the evidence of time to show that the
behavior is changing
and that it wasn't a superficial or
temporary change
again this is more difficult for public
figures whose brand and presence is
primarily or entirely online
and this is why so many of them and
their most ardent defenders basically
ask
for a second chance up front like an iou
on the promise that things will improve
later which of course they never
do because if their audience is sticking
around anyways they've basically already
forgiven them so what's the point in
changing they didn't leave
but time can make the world of
difference
a good example of this is james gunn
gunn is best known as the director of
the guardians of the galaxy films
but he'd been working films since the
90s and that stretch of time
ended up causing him problems at first
but ultimately
may have been a saving grace so in 2018
as a retaliation for negative comments
gun made about president trump a
conservative blogger dug up and began to
spread around
a series of tweets gunn had written
making light of such things as
rape september 11th and child abuse
disney the parent company of marvel
fired gunn
who was preparing to shoot guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 but there was a
massive outpouring of support to have
gun reinstated
something which ultimately did occur and
there were some key reasons why so many
people were prepared
to vocally defend gun first
the tweets in question all came from a
four year stretch from 2008
to 2012. so none of this was current
activity
secondly gunn had actually spoken about
these tweets and addressed these kinds
of jokes before
admitting that he had been something of
an edgelord in the past
and was no longer wishing to behave that
way and this
combined with what was at the time a six
year stretch of time
where he hadn't made those kinds of
jokes was an extremely strong argument
for gun
being a changed man it didn't require
the kind of leap of faith you get when
somebody please give me another chance
that i will do better later
because the evidence of time showed gun
already
was doing better of course
for every james gunn or robert downey jr
who can point to years of changed
behavior there's a thousand logan pauls
or pewdiepies or mel gibson's
who just keep reaffirming that they are
the exact
same person who screwed up years ago
the second chance so these are the
things i try and take into account when
i
assess if i am now or will ever be able
to give a creator or a public figure
a second chance some like bill cosby
or harvey weinstein fall at the first
hurdle
where what they did was so atrocious
that a second chance shouldn't even be
in the cards
some like the folks behind channel
awesome given an initial response that
makes things so much
worse than they already were that the
whole becomes too deep to climb out of
some fail to give a sincere apology or
any apology at all
some fail to back up a pledge to be
better but sometimes
with enough time even i can move forward
i'll bring up rosario dawson again at
the time of her cassie announcement and
involvement with the mandalorian i
simply wasn't comfortable with the idea
of seeing her on screen
i was not ready to support her work i
said this
at the time recently i have actually
started working my way through the
second season of the mandalorian and
it's fine but the reason i'm willing to
do that is because enough time passed
without more evidence or similar issues
occurring
that i'm ready to at least try and move
on
not to say others have to the metric you
use is yours to determine
i just thought i'd offer up where i'm at
with mine with that specific instance
i guess that about wraps it up without
ow ow
oh that's right we stuck a pin
in earlier didn't we controversial
beliefs
i know this thing is running long but
simply put the pattern for controversial
beliefs have some notable differences to
those of controversial
actions the biggest being you will
almost never
see an apology over controversial belief
the only time people will ever apologize
for something but
they believe is if they no longer hold
that belief
but other than that people are just not
going to be comfortable openly
contradicting something they do
currently believe
and i get that because it feels like a
betrayal of who you are as a person
that's not to say one's actions aren't a
reflection of who they are as a person
but there's more deniability with
actions
or at least self-deniability because how
many of us have done or
said something and thought oh my god
that's not who i am
probably all of us at some point actions
can feel involuntary heat of the moment
easier to
rationalize in our own minds but beliefs
beliefs are active it's something you do
on a continual basis in your own mind if
not publicly
so we're naturally far more invested in
what we believe
than in what we do it's easy to deny or
disown something you've done
but people just don't do it with
something they believe
so how does this impact the whole cycle
of questions that we've been asking
well if the belief wasn't public
knowledge in the past then there's still
the issue of whether that belief clashes
with the person's public image
jk rowling being a good example both in
her written work and as a public figure
she'd done a lot of work to foster a
sense of inclusivity
and acceptance so when in 2019 she
voiced her support for a woman whose
work contract wasn't renewed due to her
open
and vehement transphobic beliefs and
then followed that up
with rowling's own transphobic essay in
2020
it sent shockwaves through her fandom
not because huge swaths of her fandom
were active advocates for trans rights
but because the idea of such
exclusionary views
violently clashed with what the fans had
come to love about her work
and her public image prior to that as
mentioned you are not going to get an
apology for a belief any more
substantive than
i'm sorry that my views are considered
controversial
more often you'll get nothing at all and
silence is often taken as its own
confirmation
of the beliefs being held which can
actually have some odd side effects
there was a stretch of time when taylor
swift was
frequently cited within alt-right and
far-right extremist communities as being
secretly
reactionary in her views but that she
couldn't talk about it because it would
hurt her career
so for years these people took her
silence on political issues as
confirmation of this
as opposed to the more likely answer
that making any political statement ran
the risk of alienating part of her fan
base
this was all eventually proven false
when swift endorsed democrats
in the 2018 midterms and has been more
outspoken since then
but the reason i cite this is because
when it comes to issues of belief a
public figure being silent means that
people will take that as
confirmation supporting whatever they
think that figure believes
a lack of refuting evidence is treated
as confirmation
which is messed up but is also what
happens
because as i noted the obvious reason
for someone to not talk about politics
is not wanting to lose part of the
audience
since it's almost inevitable that there
will be people who
like your work but would disagree with
you on political issues
from a publicity standpoint it usually
just makes more sense to not talk
politics at all but this tends to
incline people to start to project
beliefs onto public figures usually
unpopular beliefs paired with the
justification that
they know they can't say this out loud
chris pratt's been going through this
cycle for a few years now
and while silence might make sense on a
personal level
it can still cause its own issues
because people start to wonder
but why are they silent on this
issue so far controversial beliefs seem
to
largely remove options from the table
denials generally don't happen
don't expect an apology and silence
carries different connotations that
often make it less viable as an option
so there's also something that gets
added
to this whole process doubling down
that's where the public figure instead
of taking a position of i messed up
to some degree or other ops instead to
say no i was totally right the whole
time actually
now you almost never see this tactic
regarding controversial actions and
behavior just because
it's a bit of a pr nightmare in the wake
of say accusations
of running a toxic work environment for
the person to say
yeah yeah i was abusive so what that's a
perfectly valid way to run
things while it it's not completely
unheard of it's the kind of thing you
really only get from corporations or
specific heads of companies
this kind of thing is uh frighteningly
common
in video game development ubisoft
ea activision again uh but while rare on
accusations of behavior doubling down
is quite common when it comes to
controversial beliefs
rowling is already an example challenged
on her
apparent support of an openly
transphobic person she eventually
doubled down and tried to justify her
views with that essay
gina carano is another recent example
chrono was on the mandalorian and kept
stirring up controversy on social media
mostly twitter
with things ranging from what appeared
to be mockery of publicly posting
pronouns to anti-mass sentiments to
questioning the results of the 2020
election
until eventually she was dropped not
only by lucasfilm but by her talent
agency as well
and since then she has teamed up with
the right-wing organization the daily
wire
choosing to align herself with an
organization that shares her
controversial views
rather than attempt to mend things with
the mainstream on issues of belief
dumbling down is
it's pretty understandable because it
can frankly be suffocating to feel
judged over something you feel strongly
in the right about
hell one could make an argument that my
own presentation on this channel has
been a protracted case of doubling down
on my own femininity started in 2018
when
i acknowledged my gender fluidity and
at the time made an immediate claim that
it probably wouldn't be seen too much on
this channel
two later it became prominent when
addressing lgbtq issues
in specific but now more often than not
i
look like well a goddess to be honest
praise me seriously though i get it
when these things matter to you it feels
like the world is saying you're wrong
the natural response is to hold on
tighter and fiercer than ever before
does that mean i'm okay with public
figures holding same misogynistic
homophobic transphobic or racist beliefs
and doubling down on them
no i'm just saying i get why they do it
is because of the sincerity of the
belief
which if the belief is abhorrent is
just kind of all the more damning
conclusion
okay now i think we're done and i'm not
entirely sure what the point of this was
um oh yeah buy my uh nothing is ever
always merch uh link in the description
again
uh this is kind of a long-winded way of
pitching that wasn't it
in all seriousness though what do you
think about all this are there key
examples you want to give are there
aspects of the asking for a second
chance cycle that you think i missed
got wrong whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
and let's talk about it just be polite
and as i said don't let this turn into a
bunch of arguments about who did or
didn't do what we're not here
to litigate the events just talk about
the cycles
so leave your comments below i have a
patreon if you really like what i do and
want to support and help me
keep on doing it there's also youtube
memberships if you'd rather go that way
no pressure though like share subscribe
is free and that helps me out as well
but you don't have to do that either
because
at the end of the day you are the
council i'm only running the meetings
and until next time this council is
[Music]
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
now
[Music]